sanfur King understood
[Music]
the hockey
[Laughter]
Wayne Gretzky's playing up the [ __ ]
Street not alone 9 dumbasses I have no
clue and the teams called like the Long
Island dragons gonna win this is the D
Ontario rain Rangers played up the
street on Friday night get a go dude
[ __ ] you you don't want to go see some
really something Larry Allman the solid
players in these under league teams man
you gotta get out there brah
Chester pine you don't know a lot of it
isn't three hockey players everybody's
play like [ __ ] happy just slap shot
it can't skinny frozen Ronnie Harper you
know a lot of these [ __ ] players they
have out there dude Mexican players bro
I saw that it's called disney on ice
mickey fells like dude you gotta get out
and about more they have unique names
bro come on brother it's a coma laundry
the goalie remember they have all kind
of cool names root the roanoke skittles
they got fun names dude they even have a
all gay women's team Ohio little dead
just a real thick team understand he
walk
Tigger's thing at number two
hey guys Chris from Long Beach king it
or sting it seeing an xml game live gay
buzz buzz great video
that's a great clean video in the
audience fantastic dude it's tough
enough to get me to watch the [ __ ] la
ramps up the street I hate going to the
LA shuffle or the [ __ ] they are man I'm
not doing it I'd rather see prisons play
each other dude honestly like The
Longest Yard yeah
I'd rather see the end of that yeah you
ever gotten to the the when the cops and
the firefighters fight each other do
that for blood brilliant yeah and you
get a black cop and a white firefighter
Wow what are they fighting for freedom
it's real yeah yeah cops were
firefighters a real like competition
come winner gets in New York it's like
serious [ __ ] yeah there's always like
one real bruiser on each team it's great
dude
what about my we didn't get cold
tomorrow what do y'all think about the
minor league hockey really nope oh there
are no Asian hockey players are there
never never
oh no uh there was a guy named Korea
what's his name who's Korea snow Asians
Yeah right it snows in Japan they got a
nice and like do tricks and [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah yeah Yamaguchi
yep Kristi Yamaguchi yeah he played for
the Anaheim Ducks I think really Korea
new generation of Asian American hockey
players but it was Korea with like KY I
a are ia or some [ __ ] like that views
phenomenal player Wow and what was it at
the XFL a la I think seeing it live you
Nick went I did I did how was it you go
back Nick I I think I'd go back if I got
free tickets but it was like for the
energy in the stadium for the first
la it was actually impressive like like
you said it was really loud in there and
I just got a kick out other people there
were people decked out in la Wildcats
gear and they were just like decided day
one this is their teams people are real
fans just looking for something to cheer
for
but the football was really really so
bad I'd watch like a half on TV that the
fundamentals the execution the score was
like six to nine awful what's bad about
it like is they're just not I mean just
drow NFL rejects drop drop balls I mean
middle of the second quarter in that
video is zero zero I mean they're just
they just can't score and stuff I don't
know it was it was kind of rough they
have some fun stuff like you can do pit
for extra point you can pick one two or
three points from the to five or ten
which like at the end of the games gets
really interesting they're really
[ __ ] up the score and stuff like
could have ended it with a three I don't
know some strategy that possibly the NFL
could adopt they got cheerleaders yeah
there were cheerleaders out there okay
alright I'm respect do not worry Lee mmm
those cheerleaders out there as well are
their male cheerleaders cuz the LA Rams
have two male cheerleaders have seen
them Shabo no more dancers bro they're
surely do what I do
fellas dancers not only they do what you
do but they're doing at the highest
level Bravo
y'all are world champs the world champs
they're not world I promise I saw him on
9news who is I think they're two black
guys type in LA Rams male cheerleaders
they're the first ones ever like are
they dancing or they're cheerleading
maybe something dude they'll do it all
hmm
George Bush there they are right there
first - that's them right there bro on
there's your brother in the middle guys
definitely the data to do the taptic job
dance on your dick the middle guy
he will meet you
wherever you want to be he looks like
Michael yo he does it I'm Michael yo
dude looks like Michael yo where's your
[Laughter]
jacket man
you seem like a nice guy dude their
users with his with his buddy
game man cheerleaders it's LA you can
have everything no it's just America
dude
yeah but la is always at the forefront
we got to have you know a gay male
cheerleader we got to have somebody who
you know we have the first illiterate
cheerleader
you know coach or whatever no we got
somebody with no eyes and no here's
video of the City Council we got
somebody moonlights as a bowling ball
you know say he got all kind of people
we have somebody was born without a
digestive tract and Madeline yeah
they're dancers that's not what I did
oh I'm sorry what are we doing here's
our boy Matt West huh
from from PBR professional bull rider
I've got that what's up guys Matt west
voice of the PBR Professional Bull
Riders are here do I recognize your
singing and gang buzz-buzz interesting
why your type [ __ ] shirt dude western
dudes do not have a lot of extra fabric
on them all right gasps spice club Oh
what's this question though the PBR was
that Dallas AT&T Stadium for the global
cop he said
qinger sting at Pro Bowl riding cowboy
we know what you two we will bring the
video look just cuz I'm built like a
minute arm from the waist down
you get people trying to tie your nuts
and ride you I [ __ ] with it it's cool
again I wouldn't go why wouldn't you go
I don't care to watch men ride bulls I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't want to watch
that I don't want to watch that [ __ ]
shitty minor-league hockey game I don't
watch the weird football you wanna chill
man just got write a sheep all goddamn
afternoon oh yeah but who's that
NBA announcer that smokes a lot of weed
the older guy oh well yeah oh but Bill
Walton want you to dress up like his
little twink
I see what's Grateful Brad broke I heard
it's cinnamon raisin I gotta say I think
you would love PBR we should take a
group trip when they come back to an
I know oh yeah recontour PBR there all
have boyfriends but there's a left I'm
saying they're all with these rough
Cowboys shape like [ __ ] Tim McGraw
over here dude when you see the crowd
everybody's just sitting like this shirt
with the collar up T here
you can't even [ __ ] see them do it's
just the same person everywhere Oh men
and women
I wish your Terrace was drying [ __ ]
pull the gun out there you lit up like
Yosemite Sam and that [ __ ]
oh yeah there's no joke bro you put even
if you just let it dove loose in there
somebody I'm gonna date white a thinking
shot if you had a great uh that doves a
little [ __ ] it's a rat dirty game set
man let's go to the culture corner what
do you guys think bull riding how where
what's going on with you what's full
riding in the black communities a
popular Chappelle no come on now well
there's some black bull riders there are
some black bull riders but I don't think
it's like popular you know I mean there
are some black hawk people yeah there's
some black hockey players there's some
black XFL players there's some black
cheerleaders yeah we got them all but I
mean I don't think it's like it's not
what I'm do growing up do you remember
there being some bull riding brothers
kind of out there no I was like the odd
man out cuz I was like skateboarding and
playing guitar and stuff like that so
there was yeah across the board so like
I don't know just stuff outside of the
black community stuff like that it's
probably not like alright I'll do it
cat would you go I would go VIN amis
people don't ride bulls we do ride water
buffalos so similar see now we talk and
not so much water buffalo dangers Oh
so you write in the sense of like that
not like that but oh you run through the
water yeah through the water okay water
buffalos super dangerous it's like a
taxi so you guys use it as a mode of
transportation yeah sometimes but you're
not in it you're not hitting it it's
nuts to see if you can hang up for eight
seconds
your wheels right nothing for eight
hours here's some Laotians right here
riding with W baby that's what it is is
Laos isn't it yeah this is stalled out
that well don't you I feel like they
would have some great black bull riders
though I'm think wha there's like one
really good one right I don't know I
mean I think he's I think he's right I
just don't know anything I don't know
anything about bull ride oh I put it but
I would go watch I'm not like on this
guy's team I'd watch it I think be dope
to see yeah I don't like I just want to
go watch it for an afternoon you think
that you could ride longer than I could
on a bull yeah probably dude I mean your
ass what do you mean my ass you know if
this had way up on the front of the bowl
what's the place by the Comi store let's
do this
oh yeah ranch
I don't know that mechanical bull
yeah mechanical people you breaking
their necks and [ __ ] on that thing
big fat drunk [ __ ] get on they're
like dude that thing has caused many a
miscarriage bro I think miscarriage is
the Bulls name too soon too soon too
soon
what's this believe it's a method of
travel I guess that's true I guess I
have seen like especially photos where
there's people on water buffalo mm-hmm
but dude that water buffalo is sharp
horns there you see the horns on that
water buffalo super dangerous do you
talk to cam Haynes he says the most
dangerous animal that they like can [ __ ]
with when they run in Africa's a [ __ ]
water buffalo really we smell like dead
water buffalo yeah hippos kill
more people than any land mammal yeah I
knew that mmm-hmm because you're a book
yeah mm-hm
ruffles the hippo what else you got Nick
[Music]